risk and reward
that one there's a gap in the human mind
I I have no other way to account for
this where we do it is not natural to
think about statistics and probability
oh yeah
it's not natural and did you know that
that doesn't feel as much fun sometimes
that's true it ruins something what you
want to be true or what you feel to be
true yeah or the mystery it takes away
the mystery and but it's a Triumph of
human intellect that we even went could
figure it out in the first place here's
what you have you go to you go to Vegas
and and then someone puts money on a
seven on a roulette and I'll say why are
you sticking with the seven let's see
it's do and they're looking at and and
the roulette table they have a list of
all the previous numbers yeah it hasn't
shown up it's due no it's not it's not
due every role has the same probability
every time every time it's not do all
right what is so what is that feeling
then that we get what is that feeling
I'm telling you I'm telling other things
that people rolling Dice and they need a
low number like a three or four so the
role like the dice gently
throw it hard
so so do you know who exploits this
about us casinos
casinos no we suck at math and
probability and statistics so they exist
other human beings learn this about
human beings and created an entire
industry to exploit it damn it's sad
My People my people the American
physical Society physicist
um this is back in the 80s they were
going to have their annual meaning in in
San Diego and there was a snafu with the
hotel reservations Vegas said we'll take
you you got four thousand people at the
MGM said we'll take you so all the
physicists went to Vegas and we know
probability and statistics we understand
the fact that basically you don't win
relative to the casino at the end of the
week there was a news headline
physicists in town lowest Casino take
ever
[Laughter]
so it's just it's sad like almost the
saddest chapter that I wrote well why do
we feel that so what is that feeling
that makes us feel like is it a feeling
that we create is it or where does that
come from that makes us feel like this
is it it's because we don't have the
brain wiring to know otherwise
I have no other accounting for it we
just don't
think by the way that branch of math was
one of the last to be discovered do you
realize probability and statistics was
developed and discovered after calculus
wow you can pick I think it's because
the brain doesn't even know how to go
there I have a I have a research paper
from the mid 1700s which it feels like a
long ago but a lot of math had been
developed before that including calculus
and in that paper it says I've just
discovered how helpful it is to take an
average of numbers
right that's pretty normal stuff that's
normal stuff and somebody had to
discover this WOW about the world
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one